son discours ce samedi à la tribune de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
sergueï lavrov a vanté le
multilatéralisme un multilatéralisme qui
dit-il est menacée par les décisions
américaines en témoignent par exemple
les embargos qu'il a qualifié d'
archaïque de la part des états unis à
l'encontre encore aujourd'hui d'un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde il
a également condamné les décisions
unilatérales prises régulièrement en par
washington tout en revenant sur une
proposition qui avait été faite il ya
plusieurs semaines maintenant de la part
de joe biden joe biden qui a donc
proposé la tenue à la fin de l'année
d'un sommet des démocraties voici ce
qu'en pense le chef de la diplomatie
russe c'est une nouvelle croisade qui
est lancée ici cela
se fait sur le fond de la déclaration
récente de joe biden disant que les
états unis veulent cesser de diviser le
monde musulman blocs s'affrontent mais
en réalité ce sommet des démocraties
c'est par elles mêmes entre annie voit
aussi la priorité de la démocratie dans
les objets clairs dans les relations
avec d autres partenaires que washington
soutient à définir de façon exclusive
et dans les relations internationales
les états unis ainsi qu'urs leurs
alliés
perdent de leur intérêt pour cette
discussion puisque personne ne peuvent
porter atteinte à l'autorité de l'otan
et de l'union européenne tels sont les
telles sont les règles
nous espérons que les états unis ne
renonceront effectivement utilisé la
force pour changer les autres pays comme
ils ont l'habitude de le faire pour
sergueï lavrov il faut d'abord avoir
recours aux outils déjà existants
notamment dans le cadre de
l'organisation des nations unies pour
régler les différentes situations
internationales il a d'ailleurs cité
énormément d'organisation de travail
log entre différents pays des
organisations dont fait partie la russie
pour régler toutes ces situations il a
d'ailleurs conclu son discours avec
cette phrase nos règles c'est la charte
de l'onu alors un peu plus tôt dans la
journée de ce samedi sergueï lavrov
avait donné une conférence de presse une
conférence de presse très dense qui a
duré près d'une heure trente et dans
laquelle il est revenu sur un certain
nombre de dossiers internationaux elle a
été interrogée par exemple sur
l'afghanistan la syrie la palestine ou
encore la corée et autre sujet qui a été
abordé par le chef de la diplomatie
russe ce samedi lors de cette conférence
de presse c'est la situation au mali
c'est un sujet dont qu'il avait déjà
discuté cette semaine lors de son
entretien avec jean yves le drian est
d'ailleurs le ministre français des
affaires étrangères dans le communiqué
qu'il avait publié à l'issue de cette
rencontre avait expliqué qu'il avait
averti son homologue russe sur les
conséquences graves d'une implication du
groupe wagner au mali voici ce qu'a
répondu ce samedi sergueï lavrov à ces
déclarations les autorités de transition
continue d'ailleurs cette lutte contre
le terrorisme et dans cette optique qu
ils se sont adressés à des compagnies
armées privées
parce que la france a si j'ai bien
compris décidé de réduire
significativement sa présence militaire
donc les autorités maliennes estimé que
leur force propre était insuffisante
sans aide extérieure
et comme l'aide de ceux qui aiment qui
s'était engagé à déraciner le
terrorisme donc bah du coup ils
s'adressent à des compagnies
militaires privées russes nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ça et cela ne concerne
que le gouvernement légitime ce qui est
considéré comme
les forces de transition légitime et
ceux qui proposent ce genre de
service le chef de la diplomatie russe
qui a également été interrogé sur cette
crise diplomatique entre paris et
washington une crise qui a agité
l'actualité toute cette semaine alors
sans rentrer dans le fond de la sphère
de ses contrats d' pour des sous marins
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a estimé que cette affaire
pouvait peut-être remettre en cause la
fiabilité des alliances entre les états
unis un certain nombre de pays notamment
en europe il a utilisé aussi un autre
exemple celui de l'afghanistan avec un
retrait précipité dit il des troupes
américaines dans le pays il est
d'ailleurs revenu sur les déclarations
de joe biden puisque le président
américain en début de semaine ici à new
york avait estimé que le temps des
guerres menées notamment en afghanistan
par les états unis était désormais
terminée et bien sergueï lavrov d'abord
exprimé quelques réserves sur ses
déclarations tout en expliquant qu'il
était absolument nécessaire que les
états unis cessent de s'occuper des
affaires des autres pays dans le monde